Is your privacy under threat?
Has the age of privacy come to an end?
Are you sick of Facebook's
lack of respect
for your privacy?
If you think
your privacy's threatened,
be glad you don't live in China.
Chinese government wants to give
every citizen a score
based on behavior.
Purchase history,
political leanings,
and social interactions would be used
to calculate a person's trust score.
Facebook and Twitter
are banned in China,
so people use
So the government spies on that
round-the-clock.
The state also monitors
the Chinese version of Amazon,
called Alibaba.
Alibaba is by your side
24 hours a day,
seven days a week.
Why should we care what the Communists do?
We're not in China.
Li Schoolland came to America
30 years ago.
Here's Li when she was
16.
She survived the
Great Leap Forward,
the Great Famine,
the Cultural Revolution.
Her parents were doctors so
they
and she were
re-educated.
And this was to teach you
not to be fancy?
The repression is over.
It's all better now.
Today in China,
if you tell friends about certain books,
your message will be blocked.
Even innocent sounding phrases
are censored.
So I understand
the titles
of novels like Animal Farm,
Brave New World,
but Long Live the Emperor?
Well he's President forever.
They can't even talk about this teddy bear.
Winnie the Pooh?
And now, another step
more subtle than just
banning things.
The state will monitor what you say
in social media
and assign you
a social credit score.
That will tell them how trustworthy you are.
The government says
this will allow the trustworthy to roam
everywhere under heaven,
while making it hard for the discredited
to take a single step.
There's gonna be this new
social credit score.
Some American governments
already do something
similar.
The LAPD can scan tens of thousands of
license plates.
Los Angeles police now practice
predictive policing.
They pay a company called Palantir
to analyze social media,
trace people's ties to gang members,
and predict the likelihood that
someone may commit a crime.
After searching over a hundred million data points,
Palantir displayed an impressive
web of information
on one burglary suspect.
People like that.
They think it makes them safer.
I would like to know
that there's a trust score so
I can know who's trustworthy
and who's not.
Sounds sort of appealing.
When government does gets involved,
bad things can happen.
What happens if you have a low score?
If they really don't like what you say,
they lock you up
and torture you.
They didn't allow me to sleep.
I was kept in a small room
and saw no daylight for half a year.
But that's China.
Why should
we be afraid?
Get out of my life!
In America, every week
on YouTube,
Twitter,
Facebook,
I challenge people in power.
Trump does make things up.
I say these things and
no one punishes me.
So far.